hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of Justice League stuff happening
you know talking about the Zack Snyder
sort of pre sequence that he puts in
front of each of his movies you know
darkside war and we found out who's
going to be playing Steppenwolf so I'll
start with a Steppenwolf stuff first
that's pretty huge so the big news is
that Ciaran Hinds is going to be
Steppenwolf the main villain of Justice
League now he's only one of many of
Darkseid's elite so I think they're
doing the smart thing in not going
straight to Dark Side in just because
they've been out Steppenwolf as the
villain doesn't mean we won't see the
rest of the forces of apocalypse so for
those of you that are asking about the
Furies granny goodness Kalibak some of
the other really cool darkside villains
they could show up to but they haven't
announced anything and I think you know
they looking at some of like the other
big comic book movies this year they're
gonna try and keep it from getting too
bloated with characters they don't have
time to develop so we might just see a
lot of Steppenwolf and then Easter eggs
for some of the other forces of
apocalypse and the new gods - you really
can't do apocalypse without also teasing
some new gods stuff so the mother boxes
are just opening a path for that but
let's talk about ciarán hinds so i'll
say you know you look at him you don't
necessarily think of someone that looks
like comic book Steppenwolf like he's a
much younger person he looks you know
like a bodybuilder in a suit of armor
that wields some really badass weapons
so obviously he's going to look a little
bit different from his comic book
persona he probably won't have like a
fully covered face you probably see his
face and he'll probably still be wearing
some form of armor so I'm totally cool
with you know whatever changes they make
to that one of the big things that comic
book movies have taught us in general
especially the really big ones is that
it's easy to do the special effects
stuff so if you need to make someone
look crazier you know give them special
armor that moves around or does really
cool stuff that's easy to do in
post-production what you can't do is
fake a really good acting performance
and ciarán hinds is amazing so I give
them you know a plus on the casting side
of things I know everybody wonders who's
going to be Darkseid right now he's just
kind of this ethereal darkness on the
edge of the horizon
like you see him off in the distance you
know he's coming but you can't quite
make his form out yet so wisely the
movie will probably try to avoid going
too deep into him it'll just focus on
Steppenwolf trying to beat the out
of the Justice League so even though we
haven't got a lot of the DC movies yet
to like actually create the context for
Darkseid we know a little bit about like
they kind of explained it when they
started teasing Justice League this past
year so in the grand history of the
world
the Amazons along with the Atlanteans in
another mysterious force fought off
Darkseid but three mother boxes were
left behind the Amazons got one the
Atlanteans got one and then sort of like
a mysterious you know warrior ancient
one got one as well so hopefully the
Wonder Woman movie will tease some of
that but obviously Justice League is
where they're gonna be focusing on it so
because Zack Snyder directed Justice
League I think we can all expect that
kind of like pre you know short movie in
front of the actual movie they did it in
front of Batman
he doesn't in front of all of his movies
really like Watchmen had that big
sequence with the Minutemen before the
movie started so they'll be that same
type of thing probably explaining the
history of Darkseid at the beginning of
Justice League even if you're not super
happy with Zack Snyder's storytelling
ability I feel like he makes really
badass short movies like that they
should actually think about releasing
those separately from the actual movies
themselves like just expand them by a
couple minutes make like a 15 minute
short film and just air it separately
from whatever actual movie it's a
prequel to so let me know here's my big
question for you guys what do you think
about ciarán hinds being the big villain
of Justice League being Steppenwolf even
if you don't know who he is from the
comics this is basically what he looks
like so you can't have to use your
imagination to see what he would look
like with crazy armor on and what do you
want that prequel short movie at the
beginning of Justice League to be I feel
like they're just so many crazy concepts
that they're going to get into with the
new gods and Darkseid that it has to be
a Darkseid sequence even if we don't
actually see Darkseid in it Batman had
the voice over during the Batman V
Superman you know pre sequence it did
the Batman origin story but I kind of
want them to go totally silent silent
five to ten minute film at the beginning
of Justice League that's just
the history of darkside no voiceover but
I think the big reason they probably
wouldn't do that they'd have to include
voiceover or the studio would pressure
them to include voiceover is because so
many people have absolutely no idea
what's going on with darkside of the new
gods they'd be like you know what am I
looking at what's this box who's this
person over here so if you are looking
for like a really cool comic to read and
you haven't read Darkseid war read
Darkseid war because it's a recent Jeff
John story from the last year one of the
last comics that he wrote before he got
elevated to like the head of DC films
and if you want a really big deep cut go
back and read the original Jack Kirby
New Gods fourth world story it's super
trippy it'll remind you a lot of Steve
Ditko's Doctor Strange seventies
weirdness like very weird psychedelic
things going on so get high it's gonna
be fun I'm really excited about Justice
League I do think that they listen to a
lot of the feedback after Batman V
Superman so I think a lot of people
disappointment will be addressed and I
think you know 2017 as a whole will be a
lot more satisfying in terms of movie
going experience I feel like the
studio's you know Marvel DC Fox all kind
of learned their lesson you know not to
just like rush films out so just a quick
reminder that there is a rumor that
we're gonna get a Justice League trailer
around Christmastime so that'll give us
a better idea for the look of the film
like imagine that first Wonder Woman
trailer like it wasn't a story-based
trailer it was just like hey look at all
this cool stuff that's happening in the
movie it'll probably be a trailer like
that usually they wait to the second or
third trailer to explain the story of
the movie a little bit more but what's
going to happen next is is there is a
Marvel infamous Iron Man video that I
want to do then I'll post my Doctor
Strange Easter eggs so hopefully I won't
have to skip legends of tomorrow this
week but I'll try to get all that stuff
out I'll be posting updates on Twitter
Facebook on the video schedule but
infamous Iron Man will be next so Doctor
Doom is now the Iron Man of the Marvel
Universe it's gonna be a lot of fun I'm
really excited about that title there
was like a really nasty rumor about the
Batman movie that just dropped if you
want me to do a video about it let me
know in the comments but what you guys
wait for everything to post you can
click here for my Doctor Strange review
and you can click here for my Wonder
Woman trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys
tonight
you